the senior NBA writer for Sports
Illustrated also a boxing host for to
zone right here on the Rich Eisen show
in Los Angeles where we had a great
Spence Porter fight this weekend in the
home of the Lakers and Clippers good to
see you Chris Mannix yes sir what's
going on rich so you were your first I
guess fall if you will 2019 appearance
and staples was for the fight yeah yeah
a Lakers or Clippers game let's start
with that what did you see between
Spence and and Porter it was what I
expected
Shawn Porter every fight he's in his
opponent looks like they were in a car
crash
like he just is a aggressive kind of
wild come forward type of guy and that's
what he was he fought a Shawn Porter
type of fight I think that's a testament
to arrow Spence that he was able to
fight his opponents exact type of fight
and still come out with a pretty clear
victors close fight but I had Spence
winning all the last four rounds coming
up big at the end and he proved himself
yet again he's starting arrow Spence is
starting really tick a lot of boxes he's
beaten Kell Brook
he's now beaten Shawn Porter he beat
Mikey Garcia he is really starting to
show with his resume that he's one of
the best fighters in boxing
so when you say aggressive do you think
Porter was too aggressive he wound up
getting knocked down and that cost of a
fine oh no I think he's just the legal
are what you are right and Shawn Porter
every time Shawn Porter tries to box it
doesn't go all that well form if he had
tried to box arrow Spence on the outside
he they would have got knocked out early
or he would have lost a lob sided
decision in this case he lost a split
decision you know and I always say this
but guys that that don't you know there
are a lot of guys in boxing that don't
want to go into tough fights if you
fight somebody it's really good and you
fight them really well your brand is a
suffer your stock doesn't suffer
nobody's looking at Shawn Porter saying
he's you know it's damaged goods
after Spidey lost and and he'll go on
and maybe fight bigger fights down the
line well in terms of bigger fights down
the line we were talking with Porter
last week and the sense was he wins he
wants Pacquiao and I saw you tweet out
over the weekend that a Spence Pacquiao
fight is a non-starter why do you think
there's there's a better chance of eysan
Spence I think no kidding I think that's
if
by the way eysan Spence is a great let's
just say Bond villain eysan Spence you
don't want to go on the island of eysan
Spence at all that's not bad that's
where I would go with eysan Spence why
why is Spence Pacquiao's so far fetched
you know Pacquiao's people around him
are looking at things kind of
objectively at the end of his career is
40 years old you put in with arrow
Spence not only is he significant
underdog but he could get hurt you know
arrow Spence is that good and that
powerful and if your team Pacquiao
you're not doing that to your guy I mean
Pacquiao is criticism proof right like
he has fought all the tough fights in
the prime of his career if he chooses to
avoid narrow Spence fight because of
what the outcome could be nobody cares
they'll let him go on and fight a Danny
Garcia or a Mikey Garcia or somebody
that is good but not as physically
dangerous as Errol Spence so I don't you
know arrow Spence can beg for it they
can offer as much money as they want it
would take I think a Mayweather amount
of money to get Pacquiao in the ring to
fight Errol Spence there simply isn't
that type of money available for that
type of fight so who do you Chris Mannix
think Spencer to fight next thing you
know it certainly sounds like with the
WWE type charade they did at the end
with Danny Garcia coming into the ring
that they're lining him up for that
fight that's fine
Danny's a good fighter only lost twice
in his career and they were close losses
to good fighters both times I'm okay
with that but but can we get down to
business and have a Terence Crawford
against arrow Spence I mean that is
right now because we don't know what's
happened with Anthony Joshua down the
line that's the biggest fight I think to
be made in boxing Terence Crawford turns
Crawford versus arrow Spence to Elite
147 pounders and I'm so tired of hearing
about how well one's promoted by this
guy and once promoted that about that
guy meaningless that fight is a
pay-per-view level fight networks can
work together promoters can work
together it's the biggest fight to be
made in boxing I think that fight should
be next for both it's in it sounds like
you're saying that with a little bit of
exasperation because of what we go on
guedes of covering this time now also
with what's going on with
de Wilde Aaron Tyson Fury what do you
think's going on right there I think
they're okay I mean they just announced
Deontay Wilder versus Luis Ortiz which
will happen in late November
if Wilder gets through that unscathed
they have a contract to fight you know
in early next year they've been saying
late February I don't really believe
that I think it's more likely to be
March or April you know given the cut
that fury suffering his last fight and
while they're fighting so close they're
buy the rights to call that a cut it was
quite something caused by a punch -
which is even more impressive a lot of
times head butts cause those sure right
types of injuries but I think look I
think that should be a blueprint you've
got one fighter that in wilder that
works with al Heyman that is promoted
you know is on Fox and you've got
another fighter in Wilder with Top Rank
and on ESPN they can make a deal
why can't arrow Spence and Terence
Crawford make a deal for the summer of
2020 there is no reason I get a little
worried too rich because Terence
Crawford's 32 years old now if we start
to get into 2021 or 2022 it starts to
diminish what that fight ultimately
could be and then you start wondering
what would have happened just like with
Mayweather and Pacquiao what would have
happened if they fought earlier Chris
Mannix here on the Rich Eisen show as
part of your boxing world you were here
for a fight in LA now let's switch to
the Sports Illustrated senior NBA writer
for the fight for LA I was personally as
I mentioned earlier in the show in the
LA Coliseum yesterday rams bucks and I
heard the Kawhi laugh out of nowhere
like over the loudspeaker system and it
caused me to just perk my head up and I
look up at the scoreboard and there's
Kawhi Leonard with an LA coloured Rams
hat on okay it's at LA on it rams colors
and the booze that cascaded in his
direction from the Coliseum crowd just
absolutely stunned me Chris Maddox
I know what's going on here but what the
hell is going on around here it's still
a Lakers town and Kawhi Leonard had to
choose between the Lakers and the
Clippers I don't I don't think any one
objectively can look at his decision and
say he made a bad one I think the
Clipper
is certainly more stable they offer him
a chance to be the Alpha on a team that
Vegas right now has ranked as the team
to beat in the NBA but this is a town
still full Lakers fans and you know
seeing Kauai go to the Clippers and not
the Lakers I think that obviously upset
more than a few people well I mean that
said I mean even Lakers fans will have
to understand like why what do you want
to join create a super team after he did
what he did himself in Toronto and the
maneuver that he made to get to the
Clippers is straight out of the LeBron
playbook I mean so he's trying to do for
himself what LeBron has done so
wonderfully for himself and it's just I
know fans can be crazy and also did did
they not see what he did for the town of
Toronto hmm I mean the City of Toronto
the country this guy's is the best in
the NBA right now yet state that yeah
absolutely I mean he and Yanis
neck-and-neck as the number one guy but
Yanis has yet to prove that he can
single-handedly kind of lift up a team
and make them a champion Kawhi proved
that last year good players on Toronto
but they don't come close they don't
sniff that without what what Kawhi
didn't look he was you know I don't know
exactly what happened behind the scenes
obviously we know what happened with
Paul George and Kawhi kind of pushing
him in this direction but I never
believed that a guy like Kawhi who's
been an alpha for the last few years he
was kind of leader of the Spurs at the
end he was certainly leader in Toronto I
don't know why he would go to a team
where he would be behind LeBron and
maybe be behind Anthony Davis in kind of
the pecking order on that team the
Clippers are his team right there from
day one they're a championship favorite
and they're his team that that I think
matters to Kawhi well in terms of his
team with Paul George Paul George saying
just this weekend that he's targeting
November as a return he's gonna miss at
least six games for the Clippers because
he's out in October due to surgery is
that a is that a reasonable timeline I
think I think it is and this was
expected after the procedures Paul
George had I think he was
he was still with the Thunder when he
first had the the procedure and they
knew this was kind of the time lying
going in and look it's early November
and that's gonna take him some time to
work himself back into condition and
work himself back into the mix the good
news for the Clippers is that even
though they traded a bunch of stuff to
go get Paul George they still have good
core players that are around and if
Kauai is Kauai they'll be able to tread
water until they get to the William
that's because without that core the
Lakers probably would have had Co hot
letters I mean the reason why and that's
that's part of what I'm saying every
single week here about the Miami
Dolphins and any team that's tanking so
poorly is that you still need to hit a
win it now button and if you already
have a good core you can invite the free
agents in right then and there I mean
that's the whole point of having that
team Chris Mannix here on the Rich Eisen
show the Paul George acquisition along
with the free agency signing of Kawhi
Leonard that seems to be just legislated
out with the new tampering rules that
came down last Friday after we went off
the air that basically said if a player
induces another player to ask for a
trade that's gonna be viewed as
tampering is that inaccurate yeah but a
look at it good luck policing it like
you know they were more open about the
process publicly because this rule
wasn't really in place but I don't see
how this slows that type of stuff down
anyway you're still gonna have players
communicating regularly with each other
it's gonna make sure either it doesn't
get out or if it does get out those deny
it and the NBA is not gonna cease their
cellphones they're not gonna do any type
of deep investigation that the tampering
rules to me
I respect what Adam Silver is trying to
do and he's doing it at the behest of a
lot of teams largely the small market
teams that feel like they're being
trampled in this process but to me it's
it's a lot of it's much ado about
nothing until they catch somebody and
I'm not talking about the Milwaukee
Bucks like you know talking about
extending Yanis and finding them 50
grand until we have another Joe Smith
incident member the Joe Smith incident
in the late 90s where Joe signed a
couple of short-term contracts with
Timberwolves just so we could get some
years in so he could sign
long-term contract there was a way to
circumvent the salary cap the NBA came
down hard on them they suspended Glenn
Taylor the owner Kevin McHale took a
leave of absence they docked that team
for first-round draft picks which is
crippling to a franchise until we see
something like that happen again team
just gotta be more careful
age will be more careful and players
simply won't give a damn because they
know that they're not gonna be policed
at all but the the the question I have
is is should they try to police it who
would be the one to get hit for it the
team that currently has the rights to
the player that's induced another player
to ask for trade because if that's the
case then the Kawhi Leonard Paul George
situation that's a loophole here cuz
Kawhi was a free agent I mean what would
you would you suspend Kawhi Leonard for
games when he signs with a new team
because he's induced to trade its it for
from another player it's a good question
I don't know if you find him I don't
know if you suspend him I don't know
what you can do and that that's why I
think it's so ambiguous I don't know
that you can do a lot that was just uh
that was a unique situation I know Doc
Rivers has said that the Thunder were
looking to break up their team that
that's not necessarily true I mean the
Thunder we're going into that season
trying to contend but they had spoken to
Paul George when he signed that
extension they effectively had told him
just like they told Russell Westbrook
that if things start to go south we'll
be accommodating and making a deal so
Paul George was armed with that
knowledge when all that went down with
Kawhi Leonard so he knew that the
Thunder would be amenable to doing
something like what doc said didn't he
say recently that they received a list
right that there was a list of players
right involved that Paul Jim what what
what was this all about that he received
a list in terms of Paul George being
signed didn't he say something I don't
know if what what he said specifically I
mean I know that when it all kind of
came together the Thunder were basically
demanding everything and they got almost
everything in that deal back so Chris
Mannix here on the Rich Eisen show so
now then it all starts with the season
opener between the Lakers and the
Clippers I mean talk about a delicious
piece of filet mignon to start things
off in the 22nd of October where three
weeks away from that
is this the most wide open season you've
covered in the NBA oh this is like this
is Adam Silver's dream you know he and
David Stern before him
you know dreamed of one day having NFL
level parity that has always been
something that the NBA is aspired for to
start a season where there are six seven
eight teams that legitimately believe
they can win a championship and I think
you have that maybe more than that maybe
you go into double digits of teams that
could conceivably win a championship
the breakup of the Warriors changed
everything there are no super teams out
there anymore there are no three
superstar teams out there anymore it is
a league of duos right now and as we sit
here speaking I don't know which duo
is is the best I mean you look at what
Paul George and Kawhi could be you look
at Russell Westbrook and James Harden
you got two former MVPs playing down
there I mean eventually Kyrie Irving and
Kevin Durant down the line this is
exactly
LeBron ad the Lakers I mean I always say
like I mean the Clippers gonna be good
and I said this to Rob polenka just
yesterday the Lakers are the most
interesting team in the league like if I
was living in LA and as a national guy
if I'm flying back to LA I'm like
occasionally watching a clipper game but
I'm covering the Lakers like that there
is like I picture the most dramatic
television show you've ever seen and
double it and there's the Lakers like
with the potential for craziness that
could happen I mean look you've got a
new coach in Frank Vogel you've got an
assistant coach there in Jason Kidd who
everybody kind of thinks wants to be the
head coach you've got LeBron trying to
work it out with Anthony Davis you've
got LeBron and Frank Vogel debate you
wind up on the same page or just Frank
wind up like David Blatt or Mike Brown
or some other guys that haven't survived
you know weren't working with LeBron
they're just coach the game yet talking
about this there's so much stability
within the Clippers there's none of that
with the Lakers they look they have the
most variance of any team in the league
they could win a championship this year
they could also miss the playoffs this
year I think both are are realistic but
and LeBron is coming off his first non
playoff season in forever and his first
injury significant injury
career so he could be rested or or rusty
or any of those I mean it really is
something else
noise and you also have Chris Mannix
here on the rich as you
you also have Utah what Utah has been
able to do you also have Denver running
it back
you've got Portland getting healthier
are we missing anybody here I mean we've
got the Spurs who knows what that might
that might look like and then there's
the Warriors who by the way would be
maybe the most dangerous 50 wins six
seed in the history of a playoff I
wouldn't want a over and over again here
Chris imagine either of these Los
Angeles teams putting it together to the
point of 58 wins 57 wins 60 wins right
and then there was maybe a two seed or
three seed depending on where they fall
in all that after all of that who
strolls in for Game one into Staples for
a first round series but the Golden
State Warriors
no thank you I think they are a a sneaky
candidate to win the whole thing I do I
do I really do I mean it all depends on
clay right like when does he come back
how does he come back
how long has it take him to get back to
being the old clay but the ACL injury
isn't what it used to be I mean the foot
injury the Achilles injury these are
more serious injuries for players and
ACL tear has become much more
recoverable for a player and clay is not
I mean he's a great defensive player but
he's gonna shoot threes a lot on that
team they get DeAngelo Russell they son
all star last year they still have staff
they still have the draymond Green
they've got a group of guys that knows
how to play together and there isn't a
super team out there there's not this
juggernaut that they have to be afraid
of like if they can get their stuff
together by you know by April I could
see them getting back to the finals and
then there's there's a Western
Conference where Zions gonna stroll into
the mix every now and then because
they're like that's another sneaky good
team I doubt there's like they they
didn't you add Zion and say we're gonna
spend the next three years rebuilding I
won't spend money like the added JJ
Redick as a shooter to a team that I
think is gonna be pretty good this year
there are no outside of
like you know Phoenix whatever you know
whatever hell they're doing at any given
time or you know our Memphis which is
just waving the white flag right now
Western Conference one to thirteen is
gonna be a tough night out and then
before I let you go we got to talk about
the East what what's going on there do
you think is that is that a Sixers
conference to win with Knox right now I
think it's Milwaukee's to lose at this
point I mean they were they were right
there at the end and the Conference
Finals last year and you know they lost
Malcolm Brogdon but I think he's
replaceable you know he was great in the
playoffs for them last year but they
added West's math using a couple other
guys I think they can replace Malcolm
Brogdon the questions gonna be is Chris
Middleton the same player this year is
he can all start once again and his
Yanis take that next step does he become
if he can become like a 33% 3-point
shooter it's a rap like they're gonna
win I think the whole thing but he took
a step back with his perimeter shooting
that last year if he continues to
develop I think they're the team to beat
Philadelphia's they're huge like they're
the biggest team I think in the league
with with all their size frontcourt and
backcourt but they lost Jimmy Butler
does Ben Simmons can he become Jimmy
Butler remember in the playoffs he was
kind of in that dunker spot he wasn't
you know given the ball to isolate he's
got to make shots to can Ben Simmons
rise to the occasion and become what
Jimmy Butler was all right and I lied
last one you covered the Celtics
intimately as well what do you think of
Kyrie Irving's 800-word response as to
why he fell out of love in Boston and
wound up with the nets and even reading
it over and over again I still or
hearing it still don't understand it I
think the question was like nine words
like he just started to go right and he
had to know was coming and wore minute
long answer and he was looki yeah I
don't obviously his feelings but what
happened with his family member that's
tough I mean I can't imagine how that
affects somebody but you know what you
saw from Kyrie last year was not all
that different for some of the stuff you
saw in Cleveland weather was the mood
swings being disengaged with the team
struggling in a leadership role these
were all very familiar to people that
have known
for the bulk of his professional career
so I don't know if that was entirely it
I look I just think Kyrie and he said
this - he never chose Boston like he was
traded to Boston he accepted the trade
to Boston and even in October said he
wanted to resign with Boston but he
never chose that team but he chose to
leave the team that he was leaving and
rolling the dice I guess to wherever he
was going yeah although don't you think
they they just called Kyrie up and say
you're going to Boston
he had no say and where he was the
Celtics had a conversation you know with
his representatives and all the but
remember Boston was willing to just roll
the dice because he had two years left
on his deal and it wasn't like he was
going into that final year they felt
they had two years to convince him and
look for a year plus they did that
whatever happened last year
and like that was a confluence of events
- because you had you know a Celtic team
that was like five minutes away the year
before from going to the finals all
these guys thought they were gonna get
back there then Kyrie comes in and all
the chemistry kind of goes out the back
door so you are doing a four City
podcast tour starting in Boston on
Wednesday and going through DC Brooklyn
in Philadelphia for your crossover NBA
show with Chris Mannix yes yes I'm
hoping people come show up Boston on
Wednesday DC on Thursday Brooklyn on
Friday than Philadelphia on Monday we've
got you know great guests Sean marks the
GM of the Nets is gonna be in Brooklyn
Tommy Shepherd the GM of the Wizards is
gonna be in DC so we got great panels
it's gonna be fun I must do a live
podcast in those four cities go to
si.com or follow you twitter and
instagram @ SI Chris Mannix for more
information on the crossover NBA share
with Chris Maddox I assume you're gonna
be down the road here because of the
Lakers you just mentioned how much
you're gonna be here so that team I just
love all the it's just so intriguing
what did Polanco say when you told him
that look everybody's optimistic at this
point and one thing Rob said to me was
that there's a we just feel stable right
now like we feel like everything all the
drama for the last few months we feel
like we're all kind of on the same page
the biggest question with the Lakers is
what happens if they start slow and
things start to get a little bit messy
in there like does do they defend
Frank Vogel is the calls for Jason Kidd
to come in and replace him - they start
getting loud
how does LeBron react to it this is a
team rich I think with Kyle coos with
being out for a little while is kind of
built to start a little slower than some
of these other teams out there what
happens if that happens plus I I would
proper to say this I don't make this
prediction Magic Johnson's not done with
his first night appearances
imagine was that the fight the other day
took I'm telling you took some time off
from doing nothing to come - to come to
the SI Chris Mannix on Twitter and
Instagram for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel - 39 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app